hey guys what's up it's jess and pearl
and welcome back to the journey
um with jess and me
and so today we are going to be watching
another video and it's going to be red
pill because i'm getting red pill
currently from miss pearl herself and
we're going to watch another jordan
peterson video
it's the there was plenty of movement to
take me out it just didn't work you
could see it on the screen just realized
that motivation
what did i say movement oh
i can't read
motivation
and so yeah let's get on with the videos
okay wait what what do you think so far
of your red tail journey um
it's interesting yeah um
it is cool to like read the comments on
the last video
and just to see
just a different different side to the
world there was one comment that was
what did this person say they said red
pill is just
taking like taking away the explanation
and things and making it simpler i was
like huh that's very interesting
were you expecting it to get a hundred
thousand views no and not at all i was
like maybe we'll get like a couple views
here and there like
i would have put on a little more
make-up
got done up for something got a full
face yeah
um no so this video is like so after
that first video i showed you that's
kind of one of the videos that like blew
jordan peterson up oh okay so this is
this is after
okay you ready yeah okay
how much responsibility do you feel you
have particular guys the alt-right who
as you say some of them have
okay sorry i'm gonna go again how much
responsibility do you feel you have
particular guys the alt-right who as you
say some of them have enjoyed your work
and so i'm not one of i'm not one of you
guys i'm not with you they haven't
enjoyed my work
i've definitely read bits on the
internet read more
[Music]
you've sold 2 million copies of 12 rules
for life you have 800 000 followers on
twitter 1.4 million followers on youtube
what is it that you're selling that so
many people want to buy
i don't think i'm selling anything well
i went to a show where you were where
you were selling tickets to your show so
people are willing to pay a lot of money
to see you speak you know what is it
that you think that people are hungry
for they want to hear from you
they're hungry for a discussion of the
relationship between responsibility and
meaning
and we haven't had that discussion
in our culture for 50 years we've
concentrated on rights and privileges of
freedom and impulsive pleasure and those
are all useful in their place
but they're shallow and that's not good
because
if people are murdered shallowly then
storms wreck them
and storms come along
so
i'm talking to people about how they can
build a foundation underneath and that
works
and
and
people need to know that because
otherwise their lives are harder than
they need to be
what is it that you have that no one
else has what are you offering that no
one else is right now
well i think i think that is what i'm
offering
that's not part of the public discussion
you know and it's grounded okay
these interviewers from the last two
videos
i don't know if they're listening
because
he literally just explained what he is
doing he's like what are you offering
that no one else says like
what
it's like they come in ready to hate him
yeah and it's like as an interviewer
you're not supposed
from my knowledge you're not supposed to
come in with
already like trying to belittle someone
or
not hear them out you already have your
your
set
questions and you're already going after
them without listening to them it just
makes the interview
irritating because they're saying
something and you're saying
another thing
that doesn't even
go with what they're saying or you're
just not listening you ask them ask them
a question that they already said it's
just like
yeah what are you doing you can tell
he's already so irritated yeah what he
said in the beginning he was like
i was i was like okay jordan let her
know
in my clinical knowledge
so i've been a clinician for a very long
time and i'm familiar with the works of
most of the great 20th century
clinicians and a reasonable amount of
philosophy and a good swath of
literature and i'm a credible scientist
and so i can bring that all together
and i've tried to bring it all together
and to make a case for
the significance of individual life and
the psychological necessity of courage
and nobility and
responsibility these things that sound
old-fashioned but
are old-fashioned in the best sense
their old-fashioned because they've
lasted forever and they're absolutely
necessary
and people need a call to responsibility
because they need to mature they need to
want to be adults
you know and
i don't think we do a very good job in
our culture of making a case for why
it's a good thing to be an adult
and two things really made you famous
which is first of all is the book 12
rules for life the second one i think
was an interview that went viral kathy
newman of of channel 4 news which she
talked about
women's podcasts
right he's got a big big following but
that was i think really fascinating that
interview because it was specifically
about men and women and you said at the
time you know youtube sku's very male
and your fan base is very male is that
still the case are you still mostly
primarily talking to men um i would say
the talks are probably 60 40 65 35 male
to female
the book sales i don't know i doubt it
because usually it's women who buy books
although men do buy non-fiction if they
buy books we don't know the demographics
on the books
but the book has definitely expanded my
um audience i would say
and that's a good thing as far as i'm
concerned i mean i never set out
specifically to talk to men my students
for most years at university have been
primarily female
i was going to say that i was thinking
like i don't think he
specifically from what i've seen in
these last two videos that he like
specifically talks to
men it's just
the realm he's in is a very
male dominated realm and
women obviously women typically don't
listen to uh people in this sector but i
don't think he's gearing his stuff
straightly towards men like men men men
it's just the area that he's in well and
even if he was i don't understand why
that's a bad like they make it sound
like that's so bad like you're gearing
your stuff towards men if that's what he
wants to do that's what he wants to do
there's a lot of people that like grew
up without like in broken families or
without two parents and so like like
there's a lot of guys that didn't have
like a father figure to look at so if
it's him why is that such a bad yeah
exactly
just keep watching
i think most of my graduate students
have been female it might be about 50 50
but i think it would probably tilt more
in the direction of female
so it wasn't like it wasn't something i
set out to do
i think though that as i said earlier
well i can't tell how much of it is
merely a consequence of the fact that
youtube skews so male
it might also be something to do with
the call to take on voluntary
responsibility
i'm not exactly sure why that would be
more necessary for men right now i think
it might be because
our culture confuses
men's desire for achievement and
competence with the patriarchal desire
for tyrannical power and that's a big
mistake those aren't the same thing even
a bit
so and it's very
inappropriate psychologically and
sociologically to confuse them
so well one of the things i want to come
back to is this idea so that you say in
the book you know there is masculine
order and feminine chaos yes no actually
i say that those are symbolic
representations of the two things right
okay so
why why is order masculine
um
i think it's because our primary
social hierarchy structures are
fundamentally masculine and that's not
the patriarchy
well it's not the modern idea of the
patriarchy that's for sure i mean so
that's my idea of the patriarchy which
is a system of male dominance of society
yeah but that's not my sense of the
patriarchy so what's yours well in what
sense is our society male dominated
uh the fact that the vast majority of
wealth is owned by men the vast majority
of capital and is owned by men women do
more unpaid labor very tiny proportion
of men and a huge proportion of people
who are seriously disaffected are men
most people in prison are men most
people who are
on the street or men most victims of
violent crime are men most people who
commit suicide are men most men most
people who die in wars are men
people who do worse in school are men
it's like where's the dominance here
precisely what you're doing is you're
taking a tiny substrata of hyper
successful men and using that to
represent the entire structure of the of
western society there's nothing about
that that's vaguely appropriate but i
could say equally well the most rape
victims are women
terrible things happen to people of both
sexes and you could say that with with
perfect utility but that doesn't provide
any evidence for the existence of a
male-dominated patriarchy well that just
means that terrible things happen to
both genders which they certainly do but
there are almost no women who rape men
for example so that is an asymmetry
there in sexual violence well yes
there's there's an asymmetry in all
sorts of places but that doesn't mean
that western culture is a male dominated
patriarchy the fact that there are
asymmetries has nothing to do with your
basic argument no but you
um
her statement first of all
she needs to know her facts and know how
to quote a book before she'd come he
said no this is what i actually said in
the book it's like okay
tumbled she was humble real quick he
said actually no this is what it's in
the but she's like oh i say tell her let
her know but
her her statement on
um
grape and the
with
men
and
women and men i don't think that
they're i don't think that it's not
happening i just think that
men don't say anything
from
what
what i've heard in different situations
men don't say anything because it's like
oh you let a woman do that to you how do
you do that why don't you overpower her
from my knowledge
and
i don't think that is
a valid
um
stat to give in
what he's saying and everything well and
i have heard a lot of stories about
young guys getting taken advantage of
from like cougars or like middle-aged
moms or it was like my friend's mom made
a move on me yeah
and we're just not in a society where
like
it's common for men to come forward
about about that stuff i think it's more
common than like really the numbers
would show yes i do believe that if it
was if it wasn't
a thing where
someone would
take it and like make fun of you from it
in a men's perspective i think more and
more men would come forward and say
something uh no matter how great no
matter how no matter what the situation
is i think that statistic would be
vastly similar or just
different well did you see the live date
that i did i had like no i wasn't able
to watch well he you know it's i brought
on um
a guy and a girl to go on a live date on
this show right and uh one of the
questions i asked was
have either of you ever cheated right
and he tells me this story about how
this girl like he's like passed out and
like went on top of it i was not i was
like i'm so sorry you did not have to
say that question
and his girlfriend like broke up with
him over it
that's what yeah and i was like
that's like assault how
not like that yeah yeah yeah
i i had a friend that had a similar
story like that like the he was asleep
and the girl just started to do things
to him while he was sleeping he woke up
and it's like yo like what are you doing
and so it's like people and he like told
his friends he was like nah like that
didn't happen you were awake
and
it's just
yeah it's tough
this is a trope that people just accept
western society is a male-dominated
patriarchy it's like no it's not that's
not true and and even if it even if it
has a patriarchal structure to some
degree
the uh the fundamental basis of that
structure is not power it's competence
that's why our society works it's only
when as when a
structure degenerates into tyranny that
the fundamental relationships between
people become dependent on power it's
not power if you hire a plumber
who's likely to be male
it's not because there's roving bands of
tyrannical plumbers forcing you to make
that choice and it's the case with
almost every interaction that you have
at the face of our culture you're
dealing with people who are offering a
service of one form or another who are
usually part of the broad middle class
and who offer and what you're looking
for is the person who can offer the best
service and you can find it it's not a
consequence of being dominated by
anything that's tyrannical and and then
again our culture or the western culture
which is by no means perfect and
certainly has tyrannical elements like
all cultures do is the least tyrannical
society that's ever been produced and
certainly the least tyrannical society
that exists now so where's the
patriarchy exactly in all of well saying
that it's the least tyrannical society
is not the same as saying it's not a
tyrannical society that's exactly why i
said it was the least
but that's what i mean so you haven't
debunked the existence of patriarchy
then you've said that actually now is
better we don't have to debunk women to
demonstrate its existence okay well
let's go through it i'm writing a book
about feminism in the moment uh until
1919 there were professions that women
were barred from they simply were not
allowed to do it until 1880s why would
you blame men for that
because who was in those professions who
was guarding entry to those professions
who was worried about losing their
status if women became adopted
women in the 20th century just out of
curiosity well a couple of different
things i think it was technology i think
it was the pill helped enormously
because
it was that development in the 60s right
so that wasn't 1919. no but i also think
it was a series of legal changes that
started in britain with the married
women's property act which said for the
first time women are full legal beings
under the law they can own property and
that to me is a structure that has
continued throughout from a time when
women didn't have the same legal rights
as men to now when they mostly do but
culture still lags behind it i don't
think you and i are necessarily talking
at such cross purposes it's just that
your conception of patriarchy i see it
in the book is that quite a lot of men
are quite nice and they do nice things
for women no that's not my conception of
patriarchy and i don't require men or
advise them to be nice
well you do talk about the guy who's the
tampon king the sanitary towel king of
india right i wouldn't call that nice
okay
okay did you read about his life when he
was trying to develop that yeah god it
was absolutely miserable and he did it
anyways we freed all sorts of women as a
consequence and i think that was nice
that's courageous that's noble that's
visionary it's not nice
i think it is also nice i think it is
also something that is you know it is
honoring your social obligations
why is it when
men do something for women
it's like oh that's so nice of you and
they don't think of
the
the things that it took to do that and
say like like i appreciate it more and
i'm not saying all women do this but
it's like that's nice of you because
you're supposed to be able to do
something for me like why
why is that it's it's our society
i'm telling you once you see it you
can't unsee it like everything is just
geared towards women
everything and anytime a man does
something great they minimize it or try
to say a woman did it too
that is true
i have
i have done that before and i'm like
why a woman's done that yeah but like
and i don't think it's cause like people
are like i don't think you were being
like an unkind person i just think like
we like that that's we've been i hate to
say it but like brainwashed from such a
young age to like
think like this yeah
man just red pill stuff
um i'm not so sure that that's a social
obligation because many other people
would have done it had it been a social
obligation
he said what he was concerned about he
saw that his wife was suffering with her
monthly period
and
had to choose between feeding her family
and taking care of herself properly and
chose to feed her family and thought he
would do something about that that goes
way past nice especially given what he
had to suffer through to do all the
experimentation that produced his his
eventual technology so like i this whole
patriarchy thing i think you have no
idea how pernicious and dangerous it is
well no i don't i really don't go
throughout history have fundamentally
cooperated to push back against the
absolute catastrophe of existence a
terrible death rate the probability of
chronic starvation early death disease
the difficulty of raising children with
all the death that was associated with
that and to look backwards in time and
say well basically what happened was men
took the upper hand and persecuted women
in this tyrannical patriarchy is it's
absolutely dreadful misreading of
history it's a terrible thing to teach
young women and it's a horrible thing to
inflict upon men i mean i absolutely
disagree with you i think that's like
saying
slavery in the us was actually most
people co-operate well no you didn't you
had a system where one set of people
owned another set of people and until
women got full legal rights they could
own property themselves they could work
essentially they were owned they were
first
owned by their fathers and then by their
status
to the domination by men and he said
that you thought that what emancipated
women primarily in the 20th century was
technological revolution no not
primarily but that's one of two i think
that's two things primarily no i think
the pill was a primary force in the
emancipation of women i think
of tampons let's say or the or the
provision of proper sanitary uh
facilities toilets and that sort of
thing you're you're thinking instead it
was the action of courageous feminists
in the 1920s that produced a social
revolution that overthrew the patriarchy
that's your theory yeah i think it's a
foolish theory well i'm very sorry to
hear you say that but i think
you in the kathy newman interview i
think it's a multivariate right i think
there are lots of different things that
all contributed to well then
assuming that the western society was a
tyrannical patriarchy that's one of them
and then other things happened as well
so you have the pale you have the
dishwasher and white goods labor-saving
devices in the home i think all of those
were really important but you also have
things like campaigns for the vote yes
you also have things like that yes so
how when in a system that existed in
england until 1918 went home why would
you even want to look at history like
that
like what what's your what's your goal
because i think the people who don't
look at history are condemned to repeat
it and i think that we're we're going to
what are we going to do repeat the the
persecution of women do you think that's
a realistic possibility yeah we're
sitting here you see that we're sitting
here in america right where we've just
had a fifth judge appointed to the
supreme court who is now anti-abortion
is now conservative i think that
abortion rights are actually fundamental
to women being able to function as full
humans in society and i think that is
now under threat in america i think it
is extremely smug and complacent to
think civilization has peaked it's all
upwards from here
so to be able to
function
in this world
like nothing else to be able to function
like that that's the thing that we need
to function
abortion
that's that's the thing we need to
function that's sexist i don't like if
anything
you can't not have sex like
that's the thing we need to function
like out of everything oh my god or i
don't know get married or i don't know
use like 20 million forms of birth
control
abortion
that's what's going to help me build
this youtube channel that's that's ah
that's the that's the key right there
thank you
now that i know this yeah i would
man i would be
far along in my life
yo that that's wow
the fact that she said that i'm like she
said that's the key
to women functioning
interesting is it isn't it interesting i
never thought about before i mean i have
now because i watched this a couple
years ago but i never thought about
like
that
it wasn't like that women were oppressed
so much it was more like men were like
taming the world almost yeah that that's
what i wanted to say i was trying to
remember it yeah
if you think about
when she said that that the girls were
owned by their fathers then essentially
owned by
their husbands
can you help me understand what she
meant by that like
uh well i think it's like the feminist
worldview is that like men are bad
and men did not have the best interests
of women so like for example women
couldn't vote but did you know the
majority of women didn't want to vote
yeah like if you think about way back
when
life
men were the breadwinners and women were
at home so essentially the people that
are voting it's affecting them if you're
at home all day raising a kid it's not
really going to
affect you for my knowledge but if
you're on the work field and there's
laws that are putting being put in place
that affect you in the workforce just in
life in general that you are in 24 7
then you have a say in it
but if it
doesn't affect you and i never thought
about that until now i was like huh well
and it came with the draft
so that's why we didn't want to vote
because like then you would have to be
drafted
yeah and i kind of want to return our
rights
i don't want to have the opportunity to
be drafted thanks
no no no i want to return all of our
rights i want to go back to the kitchen
you see i keep driving let's give it
back
pearl needs a driver if anybody is a
driver out there
anyone
anyone want to let me go i don't really
like cleaning though i'll be a poor
housewife
a poor housewife like a bad one
she'll do the bare minimum if you're
looking for a bare minimum housewife
you know what they didn't think about
everything's automated nowadays if we
just stuck it out
now back then they had to hand wash the
lawn yeah
i would have been horrible i'd have been
like no i'm not doing this you know what
i'm saying though like if we just waited
another 50 years everything would have
been automated housewife so much easier
yeah housewives would have been gucci i
probably would not be in school if
if they didn't have women's rights i'd
probably be at home with what are we
doing
why
what that's right why are we here
i'm grateful i'm grateful to be here
sort of
i'm grateful i wouldn't be in student
debt though that would be debt-free
grateful
yeah well um
good luck with that
it's a living like i'm you know i there
are lots of people who agree with me
there are lots of people clearly who
agree with you
um i wanna know they're just a lot of
people i would say
who are coming to listen to what i say
because they're sick and tired of having
their desire to move forward in the
world and to achieve something and to
take their place as adult males let's
say
who are under the weight of accusations
that their ambition and forthrightness
is a manifestation of something that's
fundamentally tyrannical they're not
happy with that it's not doing anyone
any good and it's also not true it's
really a terrible thing to do to young
men
and it's happening all the time that's
why they're bailing out of universities
like mad there will be a man left in the
social sciences in 10 years in the
universities and it's no bloody wonder
it's an unhospitable place and it's
unhospitable precisely because of this
doctrine said that throughout history
the fundamental relationship between men
and women was one of power essentially
slavery it's like
fine believe it if you want it's not
going to do your relationships any good
i can tell you that
so okay well we'll we'll see how that
one goes i'm currently married but you
know i'll i'll raise it with him wait i
wonder if she still is
i want i wonder
let me know in the comments if she still
is yes
um i think the university's example is a
really fascinating one because you talk
in the book about the fact that now
women are a majority on two-thirds of
college courses in the us
uh and you know i've also seen you
saying would you believe in a quality of
opportunity but not a qualitative
outcome
maybe
that i don't believe in equality of
outcome i think it's an unbelievably
pathological wish and doctrine right
it's very dangerous history has
demonstrated exactly how dangerous it is
equality of opportunity is something
that anyone with any sense would support
but equality of outcome it's
so what's your problem with their
knowledge beyond belief to to to support
equality of outcomes okay so what's your
problem with there not being enough men
in the social sciences perhaps women are
just cleverer perhaps that's why there
are more women at university right under
your doctrine i don't think that but
that's what i think the logical
extension of your doctor isn't the fact
that there's an unequal distribution the
problem i have with it is that the
reason that men are bailing out is
because of the prevalence of the
doctrine that you're espousing
that's the problem i have with it it
doesn't matter that much they will bail
out i don't see any way that the
universities are going to redeem
themselves in the next decade
so and and maybe that will be fine but i
doubt it
let's see that seems extremely
pessimistic when the majority the
numbers of people going to university
just generally are going up yeah well
that's not going to last for very long
why not because it's too expensive and
the universities are doing all sorts of
things that aren't
acceptable mostly racking up the price
ratcheting up the price
so and and decreasing the quality of
what they're offering and playing into
the hands of the people who are
ideological acolytes of the identity
politics routines and playing
post-modern stunts and pushing
neo-marxism and all these things that
are characteristic of of the social
sciences and the humanities primarily
see this is what i find you you
fascinating to me because
you know you talk in these quite
apocalyptic terms i think that you know
someone who will listen to that and
think wow there's a really big problem
but what we're really talking about is
some irritatingly postmodern professors
and some students with blue hair and
funny ideas about gender in a handful of
courses around america if that's what we
were talking about no one would have
paid attention to me for more than about
15 minutes so you might see this as some
surface manifestation that's irrelevant
but that isn't how most people view it
certainly the case too that this
identity politics battle of ideas was a
determining factor in the last american
election if hillary wouldn't have played
identity politics played cozy with the
identity politics type she would have
kept the working class and she would be
president now so these aren't trivial
issues by any stretch of the imagination
it's not just some kids having a decent
time while they're being creatively
rebellious at university it's a much
deeper problem than that the doctrine
the doctrines that i'm
opposed to
are predicated on well one assumption
they're predicated on it's probably the
primary assumption is that the best way
to view history is
as the domination of a tyrannical male
patriarchy and that's true also
particularly of the west which is a
doctrine i find absolutely unpalatable
and historically absurd biologically
ridiculous and ungrateful among other
things
who's ungrateful sorry in that who is
being ungrateful
look at what you have
right and live in the best society
that's ever been created you know i was
reading about some indians do you mean
me as a woman or me as a 21st century
person in the world i mean us yeah i
mean i'm incredibly grateful for what i
have but to me the project is politics
it's construction of a tyrannical
patriarchy you're grateful for the
productions of a tyrannical patriarchy
how does that make sense because i think
life is good i think it could be better
that that's that's being a progressive
reasonable proposition but i guess that
isn't commensurate with your claim that
you're the beneficiary of the tyrannical
patriarchy why not
how can it be good if it's the
consequence of a tyrannical patriarchy
tyranny isn't good is it i mean that's
the definition of tyranny something that
isn't good and yet it's produced all
these things that you're grateful for
like
doesn't that contradict in contradiction
bother you where did where did what was
good come from
where is well i think from i think i'm
benefiting actually from a lot of things
that i don't support that are unearned
privileges in my life i think that's
absolutely true that's your job like i
have a very good job i had a loving
family who i don't think that's going to
do the world any good isn't it that's a
hell of a fine rationalization for your
privileged position oh well fair enough
but i you know if you could trade it off
with someone who's less privileged i
could be a start i could i could do that
and and
but i don't i don't want to and i and i
won't and i don't think i should be
expected to why not is it okay for you
to occupy a position of privilege in the
patriarchal tyranny and if it is is it
because you're female or is it just
because it's convenient let me tell you
my political philosophy i'm i guess i'm
a social democrat so what i believe is
that you should if you have a good life
you should try and pass that on i
believe in a progressive redistributive
tax system for example it was once said
by lord mandelson in british politics
you know but new labor was okay with
people being filthy rich as long as they
pay their taxes now i'm kind of less
okay with people being filthy rich well
that i think i would leave that you're
probably in the top one tenth of one
percent of people who've ever lived on
the planet that would constitute filthy
rich by historical standards okay but
i'm not sure where is the line exactly
be able to help the neanderthals at this
point really by giving up some money but
this is my point is that what i believe
is and i believe in a structure in which
people who have had a good life and had
lots of advantages should pay that back
pay that forwards which i think is the
message that you preach as well right
you have responsibilities and if you've
had like us a lot
civilization has a tyrannical patriarchy
it's not purely a tyrannical that's for
sure it isn't it's purely not right and
that's exactly the issue but why would
you describe it as a tyrannical
patriarchy then you make a case that
it's purely that and that's exactly
what's ungrateful it's not purely that
at all why is saying that something has
elements of this same as it is purely
that isn't what's being said merely to
define it as a patriarchy implies unit
unit unit dimensionality and to insist
that that's also tyrannical doesn't
offer a balanced viewpoint at all well i
think that's probably where yeah i think
that's probably where your disagreement
comes with this which is because i do
not see it in that way i do not see that
it's univariate at all i see it as one
why call it a patriarchy because it
describes an overarching structure does
it and what if the patriarch is
fundamentally composed of women is it
still a patriarchy that would be a
matriarchy would it so let's say we take
a patriarchal structure like the medical
profession and we fill it primarily with
women is it then a matriarchal structure
what makes it a patriarchy begin with is
it the hierarchical structures that is
it the fact that it's mostly men is it
the sociological structure or is it the
fact that it's mostly men well i think
that's really interesting because male
primary school teachers for example only
15 of them are men and i interviewed
some of them for my book and you know
what they report exactly the same things
that women do in male-dominated offices
right they say people have conversations
that i feel excluded from i feel
stigmatized like i shouldn't be here
people look at me as scarce when i say
i'm a primary school teacher and i'm a
man you know they kind of reel back we
all make those implicit associations so
so if it is if it is a structure that's
dominated by women then it's also a
tyrannical patriarchy i think in that
case then men have a way of they should
be able to complain about the fact that
a very female dominated office leaves
them feeling out too yeah i'm really
feeling left out so how do we get
something that isn't a tyrannical
patriarchy if it's composed of women and
it's a tyrannical patriarchy and if it's
composed of man it's a tyrannical
patriarchy we're kind of out of options
right but well you could have a blend an
office in which a blend of people have
both so if it's 50 50 then it's not a
tyrannical picture no not 50 50 i'm
saying that people 40 60. i'm saying
that there is clearly when there's only
15 percent of male parameters which is
they do feel marginalized and excluded
so so you think the defining hallmark of
a tyrannical social structure is the
predominance of one gender and if that
was if that was relatively equalized
then all of a sudden it would be a free
and an open institution i don't think
that that male primary school teachers
have been tyrannized i do think they are
being marginalized and i do think that
they feel excluded and stressed
well this is what i mean i think
actually and i'm i'm surprised you don't
agree with me on this that actually
having more male primary school teachers
would be a really good thing because
boys need role models actually
particularly boys who don't have a
father figure in their life that's
really important to have a stable adult
who shows them what it's like to be a
man around the place could be but you
shouldn't achieve it as a consequence of
preferential hiring
no i don't need necessarily need to be
preferential hiring i think it would
nest it would probably be about making
that job breaking down the stigma to
entering that job i think teaching is a
really interesting example it was seen
at the time
when i was 18 19 right there were no men
in it and how did
so the point he made about
so
if it if it was 50 50 it would be uh all
good i'm i'm expecting her to be like
yeah of course like if it was 50 50 the
world would be great she was like no i
was like well then what what do you what
are you arguing like do you want it to
be more women-led or do you want to be
more male-led like what what is it that
you want because right now what you're
saying
is it it's like you don't know what you
want in the world and it's just like
and and the one thing i don't like is
she's saying that you should hire people
just based on their gender
yeah
like it should be the most qualified
person for the job if that's men or
women and it turns out to be 90 women or
90 men then so be it yeah but like i'm
really like how do you feel about quotas
i i think
in
i'm laughing because someone in the
comments said jess i think sorry i say
it a lot but um
for me i would say that in some cert
circumstances that a quota
is
necessary okay um
just so
for representation purposes okay um
don't you think it's a little like um
sexist or racist
because because it's like almost saying
that these like like if i'm a woman i
can't get the job myself i need the
government to tell them to do it yeah
like and i i think it actually hurts the
people because then people just start to
think you got there because of a quota
rather than your competence yeah
you make a good point you make a good
point and it's okay if you disagree this
is just how oh no yeah
okay
it's hard because
yes
a quota would just be like oh i just
hired you because you we needed to meet
a quota and that's all and they didn't
look at your
your um jobs that you've had before and
everything and your qualifications they
just look like oh you're this we we need
to check this box and check this box
this person does it we'll
train them and so in that in those type
of cases yes it's
it is like
not good it's harmful not harmful but it
does hurt the
the person and it's just like they they
didn't get the job because they were
qualified they got the job because of
something
that they needed a quote that they don't
and you know it's really hurting like
minority communities and education
because um colleges like that's what
they do but the problem is like it makes
smart kids fail because they're at the
wrong university
so no it's like thomas sowell has a
whole book on like the decline in dogma
of education that's what they're talking
about in there too
and like because like let's say me okay
i i'm i'm i'm decently smart okay i'm
good at school but i'm not smart enough
to get into say um michigan like i think
that was like a pretty smart or let's
say okay yeah and if they let me in i
would leave thinking i was stupid
because i could not compete oh okay so
if i i got like a 23 24 and you guys
have
sats we have a cts oh and we're where i
went to school uh we have the sats and
ac okay so yeah you know where 23 24 is
yeah that doesn't i'm above average yeah
that doesn't make me like like dumb but
like i would feel dumb at the wrong
school
so if they're going off of like what you
look like it almost hurts you later
because you're not qualified yeah and
and they show that because like um
like the kids with the lower ac2 scores
drop out at a higher rate or they switch
their major
even though like they could have done
that fine if they went to like i went to
school right yeah wow
and so it's almost like and it's funny
because the people that pat themselves
on the back and they're saying i'm
fighting for these people i'm doing a
good job they're hurting them
yeah wow
i never thought about it isn't that
interesting yeah because then you have
yes representation matters
but representation in the i would say in
the right way matters when you
know like you're supposed to when you're
when you go to the areas you're
qualified that will help you
best because if you're
if you're in an area where say i know
nothing about tech but i applied for
like a tech job and they just needed i
heard they just needed a young black
female to be to work there and i got in
there it wouldn't benefit me at all
because i'm not qualified but i'm
qualified for their quota and you would
and you would feel dumb even though even
though you're not because you're at the
wrong place
like have you ever been in a room and
you just feel like oh plenty of time so
i i can't count
so many times
i should not be here right but it's
because it's not because like like i've
been in places where i'm the dumbest one
in the room and it's not like
it's helpful at times but you don't want
to feel like you can't compete at all
yeah you don't want to feel like you
can't
interact with the conversations
it'd be like if the lions the london
lions took me on their team because they
needed a ginger
we need a tall ginger okay they would
eff me up
and i wouldn't improve at all because i
would just get my
like get rocked every day those girls
are killed the guys the london lions is
like a basketball team yeah
so they're like one of the top good one
of the best teams in europe right now so
yeah that that makes sense yeah what do
you think okay one more question what do
you think about what he said about
education
um what was your major uh physical
education
like pe yeah oh i didn't know that was
like a major i thought it was just
education um
the school i went to it was separated
and then anything like physical activity
that has to do with the body is now
underneath kinesiology and so that's why
it wasn't just education it was more
so i don't know if you had the same
experience as me but i felt like the
colleges are very left and like they
very much pushed like at my school they
would push like
like trans stuff like my school was
really known and like they wanted like
it was like known for bringing trans
people in the dorms and it was like very
much like the left and feminist ideology
was in all the classrooms and like
i i felt like it was very much pushed on
us did you feel the same or no no
because the school i went to was a
christian school so
we had
the first year i was there there was a
teacher
that
i think they were trans and it like blew
up that
they didn't you were the opposite yeah
the complete opposite and it blew up to
where um
that person was released or wasn't able
to work there because of that because of
the beliefs that the school had
and then there were some um gay students
that came to the school or students that
just didn't believe in what the school
believed in and they like went at the um
the head people and just told them like
this is wrong you should welcome
everybody
and so yeah it was a complete opposite
do you think a school has a right to
have its beliefs about that stuff
i think if
dang it
if
if a school
it's hard because if if i
if i wasn't who i am and i went to a
school that didn't
technically accept me but that's like
the best school for me and that's where
i think i would excel the most i should
have the right to be able to go to that
school no matter who i am or what i
believe but it's hard when a school is
based on like that's their foundation on
what they believe and they have it like
your school had like feminism and trans
stuff that's like in the classrooms and
taught that's how it was for us and
almost every class or we had to take
bible classes and we had to do an
exegetical
never heard of a college doing yes and
we had there was i've read the name of
it
as is am i allowed to say it
if you want that's mine azusa pacific
university i don't have never heard of
it yeah um it's santa zooza california
but um in california yeah
yeah and so um we had to do in every
class it was
a paper where what we were learning how
do we connect it to scripture how we use
it with that so we had that in the
classes and it was it was difficult for
students who either were catholic or
atheist or
just a different religion or didn't
believe in anything
and
they were like well why do we have to do
this i don't believe in it and
it's hard because that school was based
on that but also like they had great
programs that different people came
there for and it's like why should i be
denied access to a great program that i
think i will excel at because i don't
believe the same thing i just feel like
if if the school i feel like the school
has a right to market to who they want
to market to and it just wasn't who they
were marketing yeah just like my school
like i didn't try to make them not trans
right i just i just minded my business
yeah exactly but i said would they have
not let you in if you were gay or was it
just like if you were publicly like
i don't i don't know if they didn't let
people i know they they let them in
um
it was just it's hard when
yeah
it you have to go to chapel three times
a week and you had to go to chapel one
three times a week and if we missed
ten or more chapels throughout the
semester we had to we
either got fined or had to like write a
paper or something we had very different
colleges yes yes
yeah
so because i went to a small school and
it technically was affiliated with some
church but it was not like okay it
wasn't it wasn't like a party school
either it was kind of in between i would
say but like
no
it was definitely like left yeah we were
completely on the other side
did that make you fail i loved it yeah
you know the kids i used to wrestle with
the kids which of course can't do now
because everybody knows that that would
just be a catastrophe and i used to draw
them pictures of monsters and they'd
line up for that and i liked working
with kids quite a lot and i didn't care
whether it was female dominated i've
been in female dominated my professions
my whole life right i think it felt
marginalized as a consequence well then
you have been lucky and i i have talked
to people over who i'd be like the
opposite might be careful can conduct as
well
explain that more to me well why would
you assume that it would be luck
well if i say that you know there is a
statistical analysis and i've talked to
a broad range of people and you know you
can always expect outliers at either end
some people have had a really terrible
time some people have had a really
brilliant type of everybody else things
that i've strived to do is not to become
resentful well okay that's very good i
have to say that your twitter feed does
not give me that impression you come
across as somebody who takes criticism
very much to heart is that true
i don't think you have any grounds for
that suggestion i mean you've seen my
interviews online if i was someone who
took criticism at heart i'd be in a lot
more trouble than i am now in what way
well i've been criticized
endlessly for two years i've been in
scandals i've probably been in i don't
know how many scandals in the last two
years and had unbelievably contentious
interviews with journalists online on tv
on radio in podcasts if i was someone
who couldn't tolerate criticism the
evidence for that would already be clear
twitter's a strange social network i've
kind of pulled myself away from it so
it's not an easy place to conduct
yourself with as much grace as you might
and i think it's it sort of rewards
impulsivity because it's
maybe it's because of the constraint on
on characters
or something like that so i think that
people tend to show their worst on
twitter and and and some of that's a
consequence of the of the structure of
the technology i think i certainly agree
with you i think that's something that
we agree on there i think people are
really at their best on twitter no and
you know i pulled myself away from it
quite a lot in the last month
um mostly
for to see
why you know i kind of kept an eye on
twitter all the social medias media
networks for the last few years partly
to see
well i'm trying to monitor
what's happening around me i suppose is
probably the right way of thinking about
it and to see
if i'm making mistakes and how they
might be rectified
but
i don't think twitter's been good for me
and i don't think it's i don't think the
reply function on twitter is useful and
i think the fact that so many people on
twitter are anonymous
is not a good thing at all do you think
you'd be less angry if you weren't on
twitter that's something i think quite a
lot i've been just i would be coming to
contact with less things that annoyed me
on a daily basis
oh i i don't find him as a angry person
i know i don't know much about him but i
don't find him
as an angry person he's
he's passionate when he starts
talking about
what he says and like the knowledge he
knows he backs it so i wouldn't say he's
an angry person i wouldn't say that he
takes criticism
to heart just based on the two videos
i've seen
he takes it very well but he comes back
at you with some knowledge and he backs
it up so
i think he's just a lot smarter than
these people
and yeah people can people can get um
what's the word
like nervous or like just feel like
infuriated when someone is smarter than
them and they're not open enough to
listen to them and understand what
they're saying so they
try to
project or come at them sideways to get
them off yeah and instead of you know
admitting like like all that stuff that
he talked about with the patreon i used
to kind of view the world the same way
like women were like oppressed that's
we're taught
literally and it's okay to be wrong but
like when you get all of that
information he laid out for you
like he's not angry he just knows more
than you you can tell he's been doing
this his whole life
and we're like lucky enough that we can
watch this stuff and see a lifetime's
worth of work in these conversations
yeah exactly
i i think there's no doubt about that
yeah yeah i i think that's definitely
the case and i've talked to other people
who've pulled back from twitter and
experienced the same thing
i don't know what it is exactly but
there's a there's something about
twitter that seems to really heighten
the desire of people to be provocative
and maybe it's the case that
only people who are feeling irritable
respond you know we don't know you know
like if you put up a post
and a thousand people read it
certainly a thousand people don't
respond a few people respond well maybe
maybe it's skews way over to those
people who had a bad day like we have no
idea right because it's a communication
channel that
no one understands we're not evolved to
understand it we're not evolved to use
it we don't we can't interpret it plus
you're interacting with random strangers
which is something you never ever do and
it's never the same set of random
strangers and you don't react to twitter
like it's random strangers you rack to
twitter like it's a person that you know
and
it isn't you write in 12 rules for life
about having had violent impulses that
you didn't act on and i think in maps of
meaning you elaborate on that you say
you fantasize about stabbing a classmate
in the neck and you say you're very
clear about the fact that you you know
you've never ever thought that you would
take those seriously but it just does
make me think whether or not are you
somebody who
thrives on anger who finds anger to be
something that they need in their life
that they find motivates them to do the
things that they need to do
you
i feel like almost every human has
thought about
hurting somebody
severely or just to an extent like man i
just want to punch them in their face
like just because you think that doesn't
mean you're going to act upon it's just
like you're angry
and
and he's old if he had a history of
violence it would have shown up by now
like legion
he would have bar fights or something he
would not be he would not be where he is
if he had a history of anger he would
have been canceled before he even
started his uh his career
those are two different questions okay
you can answer them both one is
whether i thrive on it and the answer to
that is most certainly not
so i actually don't like conflict
then how have you ended up doing this as
a job
which is arguing with people right just
because you no that's not my job it's
not to argue with people
okay
so my job is to not do things that i
don't think i should do
right and my government made the mistake
of assuming that compelled speech was
acceptable as long as motivated by
hypothetical compassion
and that's not happened for me
so i made that point
it wasn't because i wanted to or because
i enjoyed it i don't really like
conflict i'm actually a rather agreeable
person which is partly why i'm a
clinician
and so
i find the the constant conflict
exhausting
but that's not the issue i'm
you're not morally obligated you're
morally obligated to do things other
than that which you like
so now i really do enjoy the lecture
series that i'm doing
and the reason for that is that it's not
political
in its essence
i'm trying to do everything i can to
bring people who are trying to develop a
vision for their life together
and to encourage them to act more
responsibly but but not in a finger
wagging sort of way
but because i've come to understand that
the meaning that sustains you in life is
mostly to be found through
responsibility and through the voluntary
adoption of responsibility you're very
likely to find your fundamental strength
and i think that that's
clinically unassailable observation
and so and that's all very good and i'm
very pleased to be doing it and it seems
to be having a salutary effect as far as
i can tell
and
um but
but it's not because i thrive on anger i
mean you were at my show what two on
thursday night yeah how much anger was
there in that well i thought it was
fascinating because it was in long
island um i drove we drove to it and we
went past a lamborghini dealership a
porsche dealership this is not a poor
area the audience was i would say
very like as i was surprised how many
women there was pretty mixed it was
overwhelmingly white and i thought you
talked
uh you know you said at the end i was
more incoherent than i normally am you
ranged across quite a range of subjects
from you know status in monkeys to
perception but the things that the crowd
clapped and they applauded were you when
you went oh you can't say that that's a
microaggression or multiculturalism is a
you know it's a scourge that is sweeping
canada and what i got was a strong
sentence that has swept canada okay well
what i got was a very strong sense of
people whose life i never said that it
was a scourge that swept canada either i
wouldn't have said that okay well
certainly i will go back and check your
exact wording what you said but you
definitely i'm not in favor of it as a
fundamental doctrine right i don't think
it's a scourge so i wonder if you and i
mean the same thing when we talk about
multiculturalism because you have uh a
first nations room in your house right
you have a lot of first nation stuff
how is the co-existence of the honorary
member of a first nations family
it's one of them i have
a first nations artist and when i'm from
when i went to canada last year but that
to me is the essence of canadian
multiculturalism living that culture
being preserved and living alongside the
anglophone culture that in some senses
supplanted it how is that not
multiculturalism well multiculturalism
is the idea that the cultures can all be
put together in a single place with no
overarching structure or undergirding
structures like that's not the case how
can that possibly be the case that
defines the situation in the world and
the world is full of war
so how does how can that possibly work
if you're going to bring people together
and they're going to be and they're
going to exist together in harmony they
have to be playing a game that everyone
plays that everyone knows the rules for
it can't be ten different sets of rules
for different people that isn't going to
work
so it's absolutely naive to believe how
if that worked the world wouldn't be
full of war
well before we had you know
multiculturalism we still did have war
war in fact war is as stephen pinker i'm
sure you've read your stephen finger
says yeah this is the least violent time
in human history so something that's a
consequence of working tyranny well if
you think the patriarchy has been eroded
over the last hundred years maybe that's
what it's down to maybe you could give
some credit to it for that
first of all
she
when he asked her a question
she doesn't answer it
she goes on to talk around it but
doesn't answer the question that
he asked
what what he was explaining as to what
he does
i'm thinking i'm like
why why is this such a bad
thing like he's helping people
to live from what i understand to live
like the best life without thinking
that oh i have this hurdle jump through
this her to jump through and he's
teaching people
obviously there's going to be hoops you
have to jump through but you don't have
to focus on that like this is the way to
live your life
in spite of all those things and i'm
like why why is that
such a bad thing and the fact that he
he talks with such like knowledge and
calmness and passion it's like
why
like was there did you did you pick up
any anger in that
it's like yes or no yes or no ma'am say
yes or no and i just don't understand
[Music]
why
why is he getting such like negative
connotation with
because the left is crazy
i believe it in my soul i don't think
they're bad people a lot of them i think
have really good intentions
but i just think like the second they
like they paint him out to be a certain
way that's just how they see him
regardless of what's in front of them
gotcha that's that's just my opinion but
i also didn't know what multiculturalism
was so i was really glad he laid that
out yeah insane
i was like
but i think he's talking about just like
you can't bring too many cultures
together and not expect there to be
conflict yeah people people find groups
but
um i think it's just like in school when
you bring
all these different people together
they're going to find people that they
resonate with more than others it's like
you can't expect everybody to be buddy
buddy and be friends it's it's just a
life yeah yeah i agree
we'll go for a few more minutes i
actually didn't say that the patriarchy
had been eroded
well you know because you don't believe
existed in the first place fair enough
but i my definition of multiculturalism
is citizenship based right so you can be
both canadian and first nations you can
be both quebecois and also canadian uh
you know but that means that everybody
in the multicultural milieu is one thing
and another right they're all one thing
and another yeah yeah well you know our
prime minister said well there is no
canadian identity
it's like well okay what is it that
unites us well nothing we all protect
our cultures it's like well that leads
to war okay that doesn't only lead to
war obviously
but unless you have people
operating within a shared framework of
perception and value they can't
cooperate and compete
uh peacefully
and
there's
i don't understand how that's even a
disputable
topic that's how you organize people
okay i i think if that's what he said
that's what trudeau said that is a dumb
thing for the prime minister of canada
to say when you are prime minister of
canada yeah you might you might say that
would agree much more with what barack
obama said when you said you know i'm
trying not to make her red states
america or blue states america or white
america blackmail i'm trying to make a
united states america that to me the
democrats are very good at that well
they they played identity politics for
the last 20 years all they've done is
inflamed tribal tribal tendencies as far
as i can tell so he can say that but it
isn't obvious that it's the case and
it's not obvious to me at all that one
of the consequences of barack obama's
presidency was a reduction in racial
tension in the united states no i
wouldn't agree with that either i think
a lot of people found having a black
college educated professor very alarming
and threatening to their
ideas to stop them from voting for him
twice no that is very true but again
it's fundamentally true right it's
really the crucial issue at hand here no
but he built a big coalition of white
well-educated liberals and people of
color i mean that is that that is the
democrat election how do you explain the
rise of racial tension in the united
states then well i think it's caused by
a lot of things not at least in one of
which is the republican party inflaming
it you talk about the left playing
identity politics i think the right play
identity politics all the time the right
doesn't dominate the universities no but
it dominates but donald trump is
president so real estate donald trump is
hardly a typical republican no he isn't
saying that he's coming
for most of his life if i remember
correctly he was a democrat right i
don't think he has anything to blame
donald
okay but i'm going to say the rest of
the republican party are also quite
happy to play i would say white identity
politics
they go they did not dump him as their
candidate when he said mexicans they're
not sending us their best people here
they're rapists right the whole idea of
the united states it said i think a
beautiful thing all men are created
equal but it meant men and it meant
specifically white men women and black
people could not vote the us was founded
on identity politics this is not some
new concept that has come along in the
last 20 years
the united states wasn't founded on
identity yes it was that's absolutely
absurd proposition the united states was
founded on the same principles that
um
what would you say that that played
their powerful role through the
development of of of english democracy
and that was nested inside a
judeo-christian view that fundamentally
presumed that both men and women were
made in the image of god and that all
people had divine value and it took a
long time for that set of ideas to fully
manifest itself in the political realm
but to consider that a manifestation of
identity politics is i
i can't imagine why you would possibly
do that i don't consider that a
manifestation of identity politics i
consider having a constitution that says
only some people are citizens to be a
manifestation of identity politics well
what do you think changed it across time
and then look let's get our definition
straight here
you can't
lump all occurrences of
non-equal treatment into the
category of identity politics identity
politics is a very specific thing it's
really only existed since the 1970s you
can't go back into 1770 and say that the
founders of the american constitution
were playing identity politics they were
playing politics that was based on
identity that's my definition of
identity that's not the definition of
identity politics unless you play fast
and loose with the definition identity
politics is something that's in no one
talked about identity politics 20 years
ago or 30 years ago it's a new term
you you can't say that people's
proclivity to identify with their group
is identity politics that's just
tribalism and that's like who knows how
old that is a million years old
500 000 years old and you're going to
call tribalism identity politics
well that's not helpful if you want to
talk about tribalism we could talk about
tribalism but identity politics is
something that's nested inside a
particular political view of the world
it's got a marxist basis and it
manifests itself in post-modernism and
it emerged in the american union france
first in the 1970s and then has swept
through the american universities and
increasingly the rest of the west since
then that's identity politics if you
want to talk about tribalism that's fine
i'm not a fan of tribalism which is why
i don't like the identity politics types
and i don't care if they're on the right
or the left i think the right wing use
of identity as the primary marker for
human categorization is as reprehensible
and dangerous as it is on the left
my problem with the left at the moment
the fundamental problem with the radical
left is that they're hyper dominant in
academia
and that's not good and that's not my
opinion you can go look at jonathan
heights dad and see for yourself and
he's as moderate a person as you can
hope to find and probably less prone to
anger than me
um
i i
i agreed with
what
she said surprisingly um i
i still don't understand
the identity politics and i was like
obviously i was listening to him but i
i would agree more with that on what
she said instead of what he said um
what like specifically is identity
politics
so what he's talking about is tribalism
so tribal so there's identity politics
and i i could be butchering i'm not an
expert don't know this is just my
understanding
it's like something that kind of started
in the 70s so it's kind of like
you're
it's like using
politics to like
sorry they're going to roast me in the
comments for this definition
you're going to roast me for not
understanding and he explained it it's
like it's like using politics to divide
people
okay so instead of saying like we're
we're americans they'll be like oh
you're you're a white american you're a
black american you're an asian american
does that make sense yeah and they kind
of like use that to like divide i want
to say
but i think what he's talking about
there's a
no i'm butchering that i'm so sorry guys
should we google the definition let's
just yes google because that will be you
that'll be the last thing
okay identity
politics okay let's see the definition
is an approach wherein people of a
particular gender race social background
social class environmental or other
identifying facts develop polit
political agendas based on their
identities
so that the pop oh so it's like the
politics is based on like who you are
okay so and so i think what she he's
talking about tribalism
which is
like the
uh definition
i don't know i'm the wrong person the
state the state of being organized into
tribes so he's saying that the us was
based on tribalism and identity politics
is new
okay that's what he's saying okay
but
i don't really have strong opinions on
that because i just i don't think i
understand the definitions well enough
yeah
i would need to look at them a little
bit more just to understand just the
difference between
those two definitions because they sound
similar
i'm like i'm like okay
what's the what's the difference because
they sound similar to me but um
[Music]
yeah
i think
go ahead i think like when i think of
identity politics it's kind of like do
you remember when i was arguing at that
table were you there when no i don't
know if you were there when the wnba
player girl was there do you know that
um
no i wasn't did you see that clip yes
it's kind of like how as soon as i was
arguing something they bring up that i'm
a white woman
instead of arguing with me about the
like like what we're talking about and
we weren't even talking about race okay
they'll bring up like what like what i
look like rather than like talking about
the argument okay and the politics
that's what i i think of i don't know if
i'm right okay okay that makes a little
bit more sense
yeah cut
yes okay
mm-hmm because like at that point we're
talking about gender i'm like what
what does that have to do with anything
and a lot of people
do that okay i it it's clicking now that
example makes sense but let's let's
watch a little bit more just to see if
they and i agree with you i find a lot
of students phenomenally irritating but
i would question how much power they
have
in contrast to the things i find more
worrying that happening in the world
today right or even the professors right
even 20 year olds don't have that much
power but they're not 20 forever
10 years later they're 30.
20 years later they're 40. right and
whatever happens in the university
happens everywhere five years later and
very very sadly for people in my
politics left-wing politics what happens
to people as they get older is that
they've traditionally got more
conservative
so i don't think you can make a case
that the the current where people
they're like we want our money
so like wait they're like after the 20
year old yeah we're keeping that
literally
so it's like what
is how just huge 20 today is actually
going to be the ideology that takes them
all the way through their life that's
never been the case
it'll be around long enough to do plenty
of damage like it already is okay but
even if we accept that students sorry i
know we just paused it
what he just said like we are
we are the product of people before us
voting and putting in these laws that
didn't think about the future they
thought about
what was good for them right then and
there and we
are not the product but the benefactors
of what happened way before we came and
so
now it's like
we have we have to think about that and
i feel like a lot of people don't think
about that when they vote and when they
vote on these laws vote on everything
and they just think about right now but
how is a law like this going to affect
someone in 10 years when they're able to
vote it's like the thing is you don't
think about how many consequences come
from a law and there's a lot of
consequences that people don't intend to
happen like the one i gave you earlier
yeah the the law that sounded good right
you even admitted it sounded good yeah
until the consequences these these kids
think they're stupid
yeah and it's stuff like that where like
it's like social security sounded good
are you getting social security no
probably not i don't know none of us are
we donate eight percent we basically
donate eight percent of our paychecks
you know that no you're on social
security it's like um basically they
didn't expect people to live as long as
they do
so like when i worked at a job i i was
making like
i was like 50k eight percent of that
okay or no no no it's not a 401k it goes
towards it's like money that you get
when you're over a certain age from the
government okay yes people are living so
long like it sounded good oh okay we'll
we'll take money every
like this percent of your paycheck and
when you're old you get it basically but
the problem is people are living longer
and longer and with more and more
medical issues so like we i
would give up i remember looking at my
paycheck and it was a couple thousand
dollars it was like i was making around
50k
and it was eight percent of that so
whatever that's like what 4k
because eight eight out of 100 is eight
so half of that's four yeah four
thousand dollars
every year
they take out of your paycheck i will
never see it because they're it's gonna
run out like it's not sustainable
what do you mean it's gonna run out like
how is it going to run out if you don't
use it this is okay this is something my
dad taught me and this this just made me
a conservative i'm just gonna warn you
this is how powerful it is
okay my dad
he looks at things as like he would tell
me it's like two dollars in one dollar
out
so when you're looking at a program
you can only have so many programs where
you put two dollars into something
and you make one dollar off of it okay
because it's losing money does that make
sense because you're putting two dollars
and you're taking one dollar out and you
can like while these programs these free
like social programs they sound like
nice like social security welfare all
that stuff you can only have so many so
many before we run out of money
or what do they do they print more money
and what happens the value of the dollar
goes down yeah and that doesn't and then
you have people in the middle class
losing
money that they save their whole lives
and so it's like there's all these
repercussions about for for things that
sound good and sound nice and it's the
people and like on the screen that'll
say oh i'm helping these people
but you're really taking away the middle
class
because you're taking away like their
money out of their like 50k right i come
from a good family so i'm in a different
position but let's say i wasn't let's
say
sorry you know
yeah but like like you like they're
taking away that money from you yeah
instead and they're giving it to the
generation before you and you're never
gonna and like four four grand times ten
years and then on top of that the value
of the dollar is going down and the
people making the policies get to say oh
i'm helping people like jess but they're
not helping you
wow
isn't that crazy that's
wow
it red pills you a little bit oh my gosh
and their pomo professors are quite
annoying which i think is probably i
agree with something else they're not
just annoying like they're destroying
the universities and that's not a good
thing and they're particularly
destroying the social sciences and the
humanities the sciences are safe so far
but not for long because the scientists
in particular are terrible at politics
and the left-wing activists are great at
politics and so they'll win eventually
the national science foundation is
already introducing diversity
requirements for hiring in mathematics
and universities it's like good luck
with that that's not going to work there
are hardly any mathematical geniuses if
you start putting all sorts of arbitrary
restrictions on their hiring you're just
going to not and you're going to end up
not finding the ones that there are so
besides i don't think that's true
actually because if you say there are
very few mathematical genes well i
next year i'm going to be a fellow
oxford university so i spend time
talking to academics i've talked to a
lot of academics from my book i do agree
with you there is an illiberal strain
that is sweeping through a lot of
universities i don't think it's an
existential threat and i certainly don't
think it is to me the biggest issue in
world politics today it's the one that i
would choose personally what do you
think is the biggest issue i think that
the rise of strongmen authoritarians
around the world is very worrying and
that's one of the reasons i find the
subtitle of your book fascinating
because it's called an antidote to chaos
why isn't it an antidote to order which
you also say in its excessive
manifestations is bad i've said that
well you can't write a book about
everything no no but you've specifically
chosen antidote to chaos so why is chaos
300 lectures online and i talk plenty
about the pathology of order in those
lectures okay but i'm just saying a fan
of authoritarian strong men that's for
sure well that's good but i do think
that the way that you talk about order
in the book is something that people
will take away from it be specific okay
so let me think um the way that you call
them real quick
and antidote is something to make
something better right
why is she upset that it's an antidote
to chaos essentially it would make
things better
they get mad over everything i literally
was like an antidote i was like antidote
helps it get better i was like am i do i
not know the correct definition
sometimes they use these big words i'd
be having to think real hard no the same
i've been over here like i don't want to
seem dumb on camera no no i've listened
to a lot of him but when i first started
listening i would have to google work
yeah i'm gonna go home and be like okay
he said this now i know
you talk about natural dominance
hierarchies and lobsters let's get onto
the lobsters because i think that the
the thing that people take away from
that is
male lobsters compete for female
lobsters and that says something about
society now that's that men need to be
dominant in in society because if
lobsters do it then there is something
that we can read about humans there's
nothing in there wait let me let me it
is book he's he's a social scientist so
he he gives examples that are similar
like in the book he talks about lobsters
oh okay okay because they're they're i
forget why they call i'm sorry the
comments is gonna roast me today it's
okay like they're somewhat similar to
humans and the way their hierarchies are
set up like something okay she talks
about it so so she's saying like oh so
you're saying like we're like like since
lobsters do it we should do it but
that's no this is what the man studies
yeah okay i thought she was just pulling
something from thin air that's why i was
like
lobsters you're gonna lobster okay it
makes sense okay
chapter at all
that suggests that the way that men
should succeed in human hierarchies is a
consequence of the exercise of power
there's not one line in that entire book
that's that claims that because it's not
what i believe
most human hierarchies as i already
pointed out are hierarchies of
competence
not power
okay so that's why we don't live in a
patriarchal tyranny and so if you want
to be a successful man then you should
be competent and that will move you up
the hierarchy and that will make you
attractive and for good reason unless
you want an incompetent mate which is
possible and and
and happens but isn't something that i
would recommend people will sometimes
choose an incompetent mate because
they're intimidated by competence and so
they'll settle for someone who they
don't respect because they feel that
they can master them and they won't be
intimidated but it's not a recipe for a
happy life i can tell you that
so there isn't a line in that chapter
that talks about power as as as the
proper means of conducting yourself in
life there's not a line in the book and
there's nothing in anything i've ever
said that suggests that okay no i'm
sorry but it's really important because
people have read this chapter and they
make exactly the argument that you make
and it's a misapprehension
so it's a misapprehension of the book
okay but if if so many people are
getting the same misappropriation could
it be there are so many people that are
getting it there's two million people
that have bought the book and there's a
very small handful of people who have a
particular ideological perspective who
enjoy developing that perspective
because it indicates just what sort of
reprehensible individual i am but it has
absolutely nothing to do with what i
wrote or what i've said or what i
believe
i don't believe that our fundamental
hierarchies are based on power i don't
believe that the way that you move up
our hierarchies is as a consequence of
manifesting power it's competence okay
my big problem with the lobsters is that
it's scientifically
bollocks
right it's just you cannot read across
from lobster
look at his face
he's like try me [ __ ] he's like all
right bet come at me
of course you can that's why serotonin
works on lobsters but it works in two
different ways so if serotonin makes
lobsters more aggressive it makes you
know it makes them less aggressive right
no that's not right
serotonin makes human beings more
dominant but less aggressive
and the only reason it makes them more
dominant is because they're less
irritable and they're less defensively
aggressive
so it's not bollocks i know my neural
chemistry so if you're going to play
neurochemistry let's go and do it okay
we'll use the antidepressants work on
lobsters yes they do we make a lobster
that's been defeated in a fight more
likely to fight again that's not the
same mechanism that happens
i think you're anthropomorphizing into a
ridiculous degree these are creatures
that urinate out of their faces i think
that uh the fundamental issue among um
knowledgeable
animal behaviorists is that
anthropomorphization with animals is
generally the appropriate tactic unless
you have reason to doubt it which is
because there's continuity between us
and animals rather than discontinuity
and the idea that the
anthropomorphization of animals is
inappropriate is something derived from
1950s behaviorism the the highly trained
affective neuroscientists and people who
study motivation and emotion as well as
neurochemistry know perfectly well that
there is biological and behavioral
continuity across the animal kingdom and
way down into the kingdom as well which
is exactly why i chose lobsters to
indicate that there is so much
continuity in the systems that allow us
to estimate a status
position that we share it with creatures
that are a third of a billion years old
and the reason that i made that argument
was to put paid at least into part in
part to the absurd marxist proposition
that hierarchical structures are a
secondary consequence of western
civilization and free market economies
which is as preposterous a perspective
as you could possibly develop about
anything hierarchies are a third of a
billion years old you can't blame them
on the west or men or capitalism and
we're wired for hierarchical perception
in ways that you can hardly possibly
imagine even our ability to rank order a
set of objects seems to be tightly
linked to our ability to assess the
relative status of people in our in our
social
milieus do you understand what he just
said
a little bit
do you understand what he's saying with
like hierarchies being natural
kind of
so
because basically he's saying like even
lobsters have hierarchies and
hierarchies aren't necessarily a bad
thing
and so like in in our society like
like there's hierarchies in everything
there's hierarchies and looks yeah
there's hierarchies in um
in basketball there's higher like
there's just people that are better and
there's people that are worse
and so he's saying like even lobsters
have hierarchies of like competence all
right
don't don't quote me on the lobster
stuff but like you know what i'm saying
so like she's trying to make it seem
like it's oppressive and terrible but
he's saying no it's based on competence
okay does that make sense do you agree
with that or do you disagree
um
some
i would
yes i would agree on it um
i don't
i don't have like a reason it just it
just makes
sense
um
but i
i under it's interesting to hear
him talk about like how humans and
animals like have
there's a lot of similarities between
humans and animals
and
the fact that she threw in like well
lobsters don't get depressed it's like
he's not talking about
depression he that's that's not
something that the test was done on
he was talking about serotonin and how
it has a similar effect on
humans and lobsters and that is why he
used the the example yeah and so
it's
it's interesting i'm like listening a
lot i'm like
that's what's good about because you
wouldn't really consider yourself like
you wouldn't consider yourself super
right
but you understand what he's saying yeah
for me if
if it makes sense and i may not have
heard it before or
understand it
i'm not going to shoot it down
and
be like oh that's not right because i've
never heard that before and i don't
believe that if i don't believe it at
the end of the day and it doesn't make
sense to me i'm gonna be like okay
that's your beliefs i have my beliefs
but i'm not going to completely cancel
it because
as a human you're supposed to learn
every single day whether it's something
you believe or don't believe well
sometimes you don't know like sometimes
like
with new information like you can't
possibly this man knows more than all
ever oh yes of course and so why do
these girls try to debate him like they
look so dumb
when his eyes got bigger and he tilted
his head
oh he's going to come for you
all right
so and the biochemistry is very very
similar and the reason we know that is
because most of the drugs that are used
on people are first tested on animals
now it's not often animals as primitive
as lobsters but it is plenty so a lot of
what we know about neurological
structure for example is a consequence
of studying the flat room worm which is
much more primitive organism than the
lobster continuity is the is the rule
okay so what can we learn from killer
whales that live in matriarchal pods
often led by uh
all right
wow a lot that was a lot a lot a lot
my goodness
what'd you think
i'm starting to like jordan peterson
like i wanna i wanna just dive a little
bit more you're gonna binge him when
you're home oh goodness we're gonna i
went on a crazy binge when i first found
him a couple years ago have you've heard
me say some of his points haven't you
yeah like in the last video i was like
that's where pearl gets that's that's
that's from yeah this isn't it's not me
i literally thought you would be like
looking upstairs i'm like pro knows her
stats no i do sometimes but it's like if
if a guy smarter than me says it like
you you'll double check right but like
why would i not why wouldn't exactly
yeah but i i like it i
am like getting nervous because i'm like
am i gonna become just a real pill
person i don't know are you gonna become
a what just a redfield person i'm like
this is this is the surface too this
isn't even like this is i can't guys i
can't give her rolo yet
rolo tomasi is like
who we're going to end on
and that's like the deepest red pill so
yeah we're not this is where is it this
is the scratch where does kevin samuel
was following that um he's above rolo
you have to watch kevin before rolo um
he's
that's actually who we're gonna react to
next i think okay
guys let us know in the comments who you
want us to react to next please ow i
react to anybody
but yeah this is where we're going to
end it we'll do
a part two to this soon so um you can
follow me on my socials on instagram
it's it's.ya girl
no girl sorry underscore it jess i
forgot it and then on tick tock it's
just it's your girl jess and on youtube
if you want to see some fun content and
maybe some different reaction if you
have any um suggestions on what i should
react to separate from this let me know
in the comments um but on there it's
it's your girl jess as well yeah and
guys i'm helping her get like a little
reaction channel for hers like set up so
she's gonna have some cool content
coming soon she's getting a camera when
she goes home yes i'll be going home
soon so check me out
okay guys don't forget to subscribe and
we will talk to you next time